so we know Trump is running are you
under mindset that the Santa's for sure
is going to be running
nothing's for sure in this business
right but it sure seems like he is and I
hope he does you think anybody else will
run or is there anybody you'd like to
see around there there'll be a there'll
be a small bunch of them nowhere near
like 16 when we had 17 candidates or
something like that but I think there's
going to be eight or nine at least at
the beginning
um I think a couple of them are going to
be just Chris Christie and Larry Hogan I
I think the governor former governor of
New Jersey and the current governor of
Maryland I don't think they have a
chance you've got to be a real
conservative populist candidate to be
successful in today's Republican party
but I think there'll be a small
smattering the issue for Trump is if
it's one or two who are a conservative
populist Outsider candidates running
against them he could lose
if it's three four or five they split
the vote and Trump wins
who's your Dark Horse meaning everyone's
talking about Trump DeSantis you know
even Mike Pence shows up and you didn't
give any uh validity
pompeo's thinking about it Nikki Haley
is thinking about it
um wouldn't surprise me if there's some
other governor who comes out of the
woodwork who's kind of laying low now
who moves in later
um
but you know DeSantis is the flavor of
the month legitimately so I think he's a
great decision maker I love the way he
just confronts big things and makes
fundamental decisions
I think his vulnerability especially in
Iowa and New Hampshire is going to be
he's not a retail politician
he's not an enjoyable laughable
backslapping kind of pile and in New
Hampshire that's really important Iowa
to some extent because those are the
initial primaries and caucuses to hang
in the Republican party right correct
those are the first two and as they say
in New Hampshire uh somebody asked who
are you supporting and the resident of
New Hampshire said how should I know
I've only met the candidate three times
um they take it seriously as retail
politics there and most candidates camp
out when you say retail Politics the old
hey shaking hands kissing babies hey hey
I'm a beer with that guy spending time
in meetings in people's living rooms
yeah not everything is a giant Ballroom
not everything is a rally in New
Hampshire they want that local touch
yeah that's not the census's strength so
look what I love about where we are
today and I'm open-minded on Donald
Trump there's a lot about Donald Trump I
objective especially in terms of his
personality there's a lot I admire about
his policies
um but my position personally and as a
Fox News analyst is I like being a
consumer make these guys compete and
then me as a consumer I'll tell you what
I'm going to do at the end of the day I
want to watch it see how it plays out
and decide who's the strongest and who's
the best
um you know I think the issue for Donald
Trump is is he made himself too hot to
handle has he just made everybody start
to realize people realized it before but
now say it publicly that
do we really need all these
controversies do we need all the baggage
that comes with what Donald Trump does
and the way he does it yes he was great
on the economy yes he was great on
foreign policy yes he was great for
achieving peace in the Middle East yes
he was great for Israel a lot of issues
which are important to me
but the question is
has he made himself so hot to handle
that none of that matters can we have
somebody who's equally good as a
decision maker equally good on policy
who just doesn't go too far
and can actually attract Independents
and Democrats that's what I want to see
play out in the primary
so your your uh you're not sure yet do
you think both of them have a chance of
winning the whole thing like if if uh he
becomes uh Trump becomes a pro
Republican nominee or DeSantis become
Republican nominee do you think both of
them have a chance of winning the whole
thing at this early stage I would say
somebody other than Trump has a better
shot at winning the whole thing
because Democrats and independents just
I see a very difficult Road getting them
to support Donald Trump and one of the
biggest factors in the upcoming primary
is going to be if all the polls start to
show that to say DeSantis DeSantis is
beating Biden scientists beating Harris
by five points and Trump is only beating
them by one
that is going to be a shocking message
to Republican primary voters who say I'm
not taking a chance I do not want
somebody who could lose this thing so
keep your eye on those head-to-head
polls as they start to emerge in early
2023. you still trust polls
you just said a month ago 238 seats and
we're going to win Senate and we're
going to have the house and it's going
to be a red wave and and first of all
you ain't the only one I think 99 of all
everybody got it wrong on what it was
uh you think it was really the Roe v way
that was the biggest driver what what do
you think was the biggest driver last
minute two one is the reason that a
party gets his clock cleaned in its
first midterm election it's a referendum
on the current president right in 2022
it was a referendum on Joe Trump
it was a referendum on two presidents
if it had only been a referendum on Joe
Biden Republicans would have had the 25
30 seats in the House and calf control
of the Senate but Donald Trump never
left the stage he still hovered so
independent voters especially instead of
breaking overwhelmingly against Joe
Biden they went split right down the
middle Democrats carried him by two
percentage points that was the biggest
factor of all then Roe v Wade did play a
role into it as well that helped
motivate a lot of democrat turnout don't
you think the whole we got to save
democracy these election deniers like we
had like that don't you think that was
also a major factor but that ties into
the whole Trump stand on the field
um that was a factor that motivated High
Democrat turnout and the turnout in the
midterm was quite High typically there's
a massive drop-off between a
presidential year and a midterm this
drop-off was was not near as high or as
much as a historical Dropout but isn't
that all because since 2016
every election has been record turnout
because whether you like them or not
Trump trump made you pay attention to
politics yes you know Obama whether you
liked him or not like yeah okay cool guy
whatever he didn't like it wasn't
must-see TV Trump must see TV I don't
know if you know that or not massive
um but he
the
what I will give him credit for is
you know he woke a lot of people up
whether you like him or you know don't
like them support them or do not support
him this record turnout is all due to
him for the last eight years right I
agree
well I agree I mean 16 broke all the
records and then 20 broke all the
records and now 22 for for midterms what
do you think 28 18 at a higher turnout
than 22. okay but that was the first
year of trump midterm well he got
crushed it was it's about the midterm
and this is why this whole notion of
democracy is in trouble yeah democracy
is freaking thriving that's why people
are turning out so much whether you love
Trump or you hate Trump or democracy
functions it works yeah you know I could
make the case that there's a reason for
low turnouts because people are happy
when things are good and calm you don't
have to turn out all of a sudden people
see a threat to America Donald Trump or
I love Donald Trump so we have massive
turnout that's a healthy thriving
democracy and what settled it the will
of the people
that's what makes a democracy work so
what all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks right if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks right
here future looks bright here we got
them in white we got them in Black we
got them in red are black on black sold
out these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people weren't in
the office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hats especially during times like
this because ain't nobody's saying
future looks spread toward your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
foreign
[Music]